um so tonight uh for those who don't
know maybe Who I am
my job I'm in icon Carver which is a bit
strange for for some people there aren't
that many icon Carver's actually
probably I'm they're probably in America
like one I think maybe two maybe there
maybe two there's more in there are more
in Greece are more in Russia obviously
but it's not something that is very
useful yeah very hope it's useful not
something that's very usual hope that
wasn't a little Freudian slip there it's
not very usual and as I discovered
traditional art and Orthodox art you
know learning my own skill but also
exploring the icons themselves and their
symbolism and the relationships between
the icons and Scripture and the liturgy
and the architecture and really
discovering this beautiful pattern that
we have in our faith that's been passed
down and kept for for thousands of years
now it's something that I find a lot of
joy in and so one of the things I'm also
doing is I'm I'm on making youtube
videos and I talked about some of this
stuff I talked about iconography but
also how the traditional symbolism that
we have in our liturgy in our icons in
Scripture how it actually connects to
everyday life and especially how this is
what I'm going to try to show you
tonight that the icon of the Nativity
it's not just an image of a moment in
history when a young child was born but
it's actually an image of reality it's a
it's an image which shows us how reality
lays itself out for us and so hopefully
we'll be able to go through the the icon
and I'll be able to show you how
profound our faces and how profound
these images are these images obviously
the problem a lot with a lot of these
images is that we come to take them for
granted obviously we we've seen them so
much that they kind of go into the
background of our minds but it's always
good to go back
into them and let's say reawaken our our
sensitivity to see what's really going
on in some of these images
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
now I wanted to start with this just
because this is where we're going
everybody knows it's November we're
going towards this we're going towards
this this kind of crazy excess of
everything for the holidays this is the
celebration of the bells the velvet the
gold and all of that and we're used to
it we see it happen every year but we as
Orthodox Christians we have this past
here it's it's obviously quite a
contrast as we're watching everybody
partying around us that we have this
fast it's it's I have to admit that it's
a much harder fast to follow than Lent
because it's just a lot harder because
there's so much going on everybody
celebrating but I think we can at least
look at why would we have a fast what is
it that we're preparing for because
that's the point of the fast that's the
point of Lent and that's also the point
of this fast what is it that we're
preparing for what's the why is it such
a big deal for this notion of the
Nativity or the Incarnation you know we
we always have as Christians most of us
we always have this trope where we say
like what's the real you know we we have
Christmas we celebrate we give gifts you
have all that no Santa we have
everything we asked like what's the real
reason for Christmas and we all have the
answer right right it's the birth of
Christ that's the answer but we need to
go more into it what's why is it such a
big deal and in the icon of the Nativity
we can see with our eyes the way that
the icon is made why that's such a big
deal how it shows us this so
so I put in I put in one one of the
icons that I've carved just so you can
see for those who haven't seen my work
but um so everybody knows the icon of
the Nativity does everybody understand
what's happening maybe I'll go through
the elements of the icon just so that
people kind of understand what what's
going on first because it is a
complicated icon for a feast so we have
the mother of God in the center who's
lying down on a mat or she's resting
after I've been given birth we have of
course Christ the Christ child who's
laying down in the manger surrounding
him is the ass and the Ox by the way the
ass and the Ox is one of the oldest
elements of the Nativity it doesn't say
in Scripture that there's an ass and an
ox specifically but it is it is one of
the oldest elements in the first images
we have where we see Christ in a manger
we see the ass and the ox there are some
images from the the third century where
you just see a manger with Christ and an
acident ox on each side we'll get to why
that's important it's very important we
have the three wise men who are coming
to encounter Christ here we have a
shepherd who is blowing his horn
celebrating at the top we have the three
angels that are announcing the birth of
Christ here that you can see it in this
one can you see what it is
everybody see right that's a star and
above the star is a glory so different
ways of showing you but it's a glory
which shows us in a symbolic manner the
presence of God now down below we have
two scenes we have we'll start here we
have the washing of the Christ child and
we have Saint Joseph who is being
tempted by a shepherd / devil so those
are the canonical images the canonical
elements of the icon is there before I
start explaining some of the elements
are there some things that you've never
seen or that you're surprised to hear Oh
like when I said Jo's are being tempted
by a devil I saw a few people
sneering in the audience is that
possible does everybody know that story
okay so in the in the tradition there is
there is a story which talks about it
comes from the protoevangelium of james
which is the the book out of which most
of our traditions for for the mother of
god and for the nativity come from
outside of the bible and in that book
you have this scene where Joseph is not
permitted to be there when when the
mother of God gives birth in imagine
we're so used to our modern way of
thinking with the dad you know in the
hospital with the with the doctor but
that is not the traditional way that a
woman would have given birth
a woman would give birth with what's the
word in English midwives there you go
sorry my French is going to come back so
with midwives and so Joseph was told to
leave the the place where where Christ
is born and so then he's mulling over in
his mind and he's thinking like is this
really possible is this for real it's
like he knows he's not the father
so he's wondering like is this is this
the real deal is is is this really the
birth from a virgin and it's the this
devil figure who is tempting and I knew
saying like who's asking him questions
and one and getting him to wonder
whether or not this is actually possible
and then the midwives are the ones who
are here washing the Christ child so
those are the basic elements after the
ass and the Ox that is also a very very
ancient tradition also the other
tradition which is quite old is the fact
that Christ was born in a cave now that
in Scripture it doesn't say that the
only thing it says in Scripture is that
Christ was laid in a manger which means
that Christ was laid in a food trough
for animals that's what a manger is
sometimes we forget a manger is
basically a food trough for animals and
so it doesn't say that he was born in a
stable or born like we know we have
these little images of nativities with
Christ in the little stable but the
tradition from very early from the first
century we have in st. Justin Martyr
talks about how Christ was born in a
cave okay so those are the basic
elements of the the the icon and the way
they're laid out first of all can help
us understand something about
iconography which is icons are not
snapshots you know they're not just
someone who would come at on an event
and just take a picture of something
that's going on because all of these
events are happening at different times
the and different places right the wise
men were in the East when they saw the
star and when they arrived at at the the
place where Christ was it was like a
year later several several months later
okay and then here's the mother of God
giving birth but then here's Christ here
and then here's Christ here again being
washed and so what the icon does is it
compresses things together right it
takes these different elements of the
story and it brings them into one place
where you can see things in their
meaning you could say how all these
elements in
story come together and participate in
the meaning and so you can give us it
can give us a different sense of what
these things mean and how they how they
come together so what you see for
example in the icon you see it quite
clearly you see this joining of these
kind of you could say these wild
opposites you have the these angels up
above right you have this kind of
demonic figure there below you have
these wise men who are from very very
far away
and who are probably an elite Nobles in
the West they were considered Kings who
say the three wise Kings and so they're
they're the elite and but they're also
from far away and then you have these
homely shepherds who are just the guys
next door who are participating in this
event and so look at how the icon is
actually brought together right the
whole thing is like a bull's eye right
it is concentric this constricted
concentric structure you have something
going on in the middle which brings
together everything from everything
that's around it and that already starts
to tell us a little bit of the mystery
of what it is that's happening on in
that moment what it is that's going on
what is this Christ child what is he
what is he for us and the first thing
that we can see is that he's bringing
together all these opposites you could
say something like he's gathering
together you know all of creation all of
everything gathering it together into
himself and once you start to see that
then you start to understand also when I
told you about the ass and the ox this
is a little bit more kind of esoteric
but just bear with me you'll see how it
makes sense the ass and the Ox
relate to Old Testament laws so there
were foods in the Old Testament which
people could eat today Jews taught me
kosher food and there are some foods
that people couldn't eat they were
impure food
now the ox is a pure food and the ass of
the donkey is an impure poop they're not
allowed to eat donkeys
so because of that the donkey becomes
becomes in the the symbolism an image
for us actually most of us I don't know
are there any Jews here
maybe not but for all the all the
nations let's say all those that aren't
Jewish and you you read in the Church
Fathers they talk about this ass and
this ox as in the end there's a law and
the Old Testament which says you cannot
yoke an ass and an ox together if you're
gonna plows it's like that's a very
strange law for people you know
especially for kind of atheist types
they always like that they want to make
fun of the Bible they'll say here's this
crazy law which said that you can't yoke
and ask and it ox together but what it
meant is exactly is what I told you is
that you cannot bring together the
outside and the inside you cannot join
with the foreigners you cannot mix the
pure the impure but Christ brings us a
different vision of the world brings us
a different reality where in fact he
does I would say Christ is the only one
who's allowed to break that law because
he does in fact bring the ass and the ox
together and he does it and we see it
happen in this icon and so the ass in
the Ox become this image of how the Jews
and the Gentiles are going to join
together and the church will be born out
of that out of that Union and I'm not
making this stuff up by the way you can
read have the quotes but in the church
fathers these explicitly talk about this
symbolism now the other kind of let's
say strange element or important element
is the cave why does Christ have to be
born in
one of the the secrets to kind of
understanding why Christ has to be born
in a cave is if you look at the manger
so look at the look at the manger what
does it look like sorry yes that's
exactly and so the manger is is already
too
and so this descent into the cave this
this this image of Christ being born in
a cave is already showing us what the
whole story is about what the whole
story is about which is it is already
this descent into death and the descent
into death appears you know we symbolize
the imagery of the of the manger as as a
tomb but the manger itself is already an
image of that this idea of descending
down into animality descending down into
the the place of animals that is the
state of the fall itself right when Adam
and Eve fell in the garden God gave them
these garments of animal skins to cover
them and so this idea of descending into
the place of the animal is this descent
into death and the early Christians knew
that very very well they would actually
create images which would link all of
those things together a good example
here in the these are images taken from
the catacombs so these are images taken
from literally from the graves of
Christians and so what do they represent
in the space of death they represent
something which is akin to what we saw
that is these three images this is can
anybody guess what that image of is of
there
yeah it's Noah's Ark it's very strange
Noah's Ark but that's Noah's Ark you can
tell because you see if he's got a bird
and he's got this this giant box flop
floating in in water who can guess what
this one is
yes Jonah and then this one you can read
his name is written so it's not that
hard so there's Daniel in the lion's den
so there are three images three images
from the Old Testament which help us see
what it is that's going on this descent
into death this descent into cave this
descent into the place of animals into
into the animal existence you could say
which is that existence of death and so
the image of of Christ it's it's you
know and I and I talked about that and I
feel like maybe I'm actually ruining
Christmas for you because because
Christmas we celebrate and it's fine we
should celebrate Christmas we should but
in our icon we have a reminder of
something which is far more austere
something which is far more serious than
just this kind of celebration of the
birth of a child there are other images
of Christ's other icons of Christ which
happened underground you would say and
we've got two of them one is this one
everybody know what this is right the
baptism of Christ and the other I'll
show I'll show it later the other is the
Anastasis
which is Christ descending into death
those two images happen underground and
those two images are also images of
Christ descending into death so you have
this like repeated pattern from the
Nativity of Christ descending into death
and then the the baptism of Christ and
the Anastasis
here in this version of the Anastasis of
the of the baptism he's actually
standing on the doors of death
just like in the icon of the
resurrection so in the icon of the
resurrection here's another one of my
carvings if you want to know another one
of the resurrect in the icon of the
Resurrection you see Christ standing on
the doors of death alright so why why
why is it I'm telling you that this is
an image of reality this icon is
actually a picture of how the world
works why is that so well there there
there are a few things this idea of the
Christ child God told Gabriel told Saint
Gabriel told the mother of God to name
her child Emmanuel and what does
Emmanuel mean yes God with us or God in
us right so it is it is both this
descent of Christ into the cave is of
course this descent of the origin of the
universe into the world and in a way
it's like this this this story obviously
is a total scandal you can understand
why people rejected it it is a crazy
story there's a crazy story to say that
God that the logos that the divine logos
which created the world would become a
person would enter into the world and
reveal himself in this specific moment
you know in history anything it is an
insanely crazy story but at the same
time it's not a scandal because what
it's showing us it's showing us how
reality actually works
it's showing us the mystery that say
Paul announced that say st. Paul talk to
us about what is this mystery of the
Incarnation and he says that Christ has
revealed
to us the mystery that was hidden for
all ages and generation but is now
revealed to his Saints and what is this
mystery it is Christ in you the hope of
glory you know we say as order Orthodox
people and we repeat it all the time we
say God became man so that man could
become God that his Christ is revealing
us the manner in which the world
actually exists everything in the world
and when I say and when you say Christ
and you it's not just Christ in you but
Christ in everything Christ in the world
God is hidden in the world just like
Christ is born
hidden in this cave God is of course
there are difference of levels here we
have to be careful I'm not saying that
the whole world is the Incarnation but
the Incarnation is showing us how God is
hiding in the world and is hiding behind
phenomena and in fact without without
this divine spark or this child this
invisible thing which is hidden inside
all phenomena the world doesn't exist
and I'm saying this like I'm saying this
very technically I'm not saying it in a
way that that that is just I'm not just
spouting this off the world is actually
the world is made of too much stuff
everything in the world scatters into
details why is it that this microphone
how is it that you say that it's a
microphone
why don't you see all its parts without
without seeing that it's one thing
there's something about the world the
way the world works which which makes
the world come together into unity and
that's for anything any object anything
in the world
everything has multiple multiple
multiple parts an indefinite infinite
amount of parts why how is it that we
can say that that that some things exist
and you hear like people kind of talking
that people say that like it's all just
a quantum flux right it's all just flux
there that nothing is actually real if
you take the microphone you could say
this is this is a wire and it's a mesh
of steel and it's black paint and it's
white paint and I could keep going and
keep going keep going I could describe
the microphone forever without ever
saying that it's a microphone how is it
that I can see that it is something and
it's a mystery we can't totally know
exactly how it works but what we do know
is that that is that is the that is the
ontology that we are living and that is
the the worldview that the Orthodox
Christian lives in say Maximus the
Confessor talks about this explicitly he
talks about how hidden in the world are
these purposes these hidden
kernels that bring things together that
make us make us actually make the world
exist and so when we see Christ coming
down into this cave hidden in the world
it is an image of how the world exists
and when we see st. Joseph there
doubting and asking himself is this just
possible is this possible
that someone can be born of a virgin
what is he asking
he's asking a huge question
he's act he's asking the question he's
asking how is it possible for there for
something to come out of nothing how is
it possible for this union between the
spiritual and the physical to happen how
is it possible that we that the world
exists ultimately that is what he's
asking when we talk of the mother of God
we use certain terms which are very very
strong to help us understand this
mystery we say that that that Christ
that she that she how do you say how do
we say it that her womb contained that
who him who the world cannot contain or
that the cosmos cannot contain and so
she contained into her womb that which
could not be contained and it is and it
is appointing right it is appointing to
the mystery right there even from the
beginning of Scripture it is linking us
to that beginning of Scripture of this
primordial primordial earth and then you
see the the word come down and the Word
of God which manifests the world out of
this primordial waters right this image
is is helping a see what the mystery is
about and you see that ray of light
coming down that star that comes down
it's not it's not arbitrary that they
showed it like this ray of light which
comes down and point and points to this
hidden kernel it's hidden reason why the
world exists this hidden reason why
things exist
so I think what's important I mean
what's important is what a few things
that are important one is to understand
what it is that we're celebrating and to
to understand especially that we have
we've been in a certain ways we've been
we've been ruined by the modern world
we've been told that as Christians we
believe these things and these things
are arbitrary that here it is you know I
there are these things that I believe
and there's somewhat arbitrary and here
it is that I believe them but that is
not the case what we believe our faith
is real it is the things that we that it
talks about the things that it manifests
to us it manifests what's really the
mysteries of how the world exists
because the question that that that st.
Joseph is asking himself that's the
question that the Atheist asks himself -
about the entire cosmos how is it
possible why is there something rather
than nothing
you you can hear you can hear the
physicians that the the physicists asked
that today it's like they say the Big
Bang it's like why is there something
how did something come out of nothing
those questions these those questions
are being asked today and the
Incarnation is obviously to be careful
and not I'm not saying that this is all
the same thing right I'm trying to help
you show that the incarnation of Christ
brings us into the very manner in which
the world exists and anchors us to a way
that we can understand but not not just
understand but participate in how the
world exists and so what I would like to
suggest is that that is what we are
preparing for and you know that it's not
totally arbitrary the fact that
Christmas nativity comes
around the time of the Solstice you know
I I don't think that it's purposeful in
the sense that a lot of people think
that somehow Christians just took over
the pagan holidays actually I don't
think that that's how it happened but it
isn't all so arbitrary because that's
the that's this in the time of the
Solstice is what happens this secret
mystery - you can imagine it's hard now
because we live in the city and we have
lights and everything but we can imagine
the Sun going down and down and down and
down and there's this darkness which is
rising and rising and rising and you
think and you wonder do you think how
far is it gonna go if the Sun gonna
vanish is the Sun gonna go away is it
going to end is this going to finish and
then in that secret place as the Sun is
at its lowest point in that secret place
is where the Sun is born again and we
don't see it right away right it's the
mystery we don't see it until
mid-january we don't realize that the
days are getting longer and and again
that image is the same image as what
we're seeing here but here's the light
which comes down and manifest itself in
the secret place in this hidden spark
which is there and which will grow and
start to reveal itself and then and then
you know and we'll go all the way into
into pasca to the final kind of glorious
manifestation of what was already
started here it was already intimated in
the very story of the birth of our Lord
so that is what I want to encourage you
today mostly to kind of understand how
important it is and also in the Orthodox
faith we have kept what I believe to be
the most complete and the most profound
understanding and version of this in our
hymns in our icons in our liturgy and in
the writings of the fathers we have kept
the most profound version of this and so
we do have an answer to you know the the
crazy commodification of Christmas
and this is our answer and we know how
deep it goes it goes to the bottom of
the world so thank you very much so I
know that we said that if anybody has
questions you can be about this but it
could also be about anything else if you
want to ask questions about iconography
or about you know the strange fellow
whose cars icons then then the floor is
open
yeah yeah the two strange disturbing
figures I will tell you what they are
let's put them up and I'll tell you what
that these guys okay so so that is the
the sea and the Jordan it's actually a
their representations of of the waters
so there's a there's a there's a psalm
in which it is said that the sea and the
jordan receded before the Lord that they
that they kind of made way for the Lord
and so this is the representation of the
Jordan and the sea kind of making way
for their Lord who's coming down but
there's something more very interesting
about this as well is that the way in
which they're represented they're
represented as old gods they're like old
river gods these are these are Roman
like Roman River gods and River nymphs
and whatever does all these kind of
weird Roman gods and so what happens is
that not only are the seas and the
rivers kind of making way for Christ but
the old gods are making way for Christ
as well and they're kind of getting out
of the way to make way for Christ and
and you have this image you know we we
talk about baptism you know you go in to
baptism and then you come out and you
person and you leave something down in
the waters right you leave the the I'd
say that the chaotic aspect of yourself
or the the aspect of yourself which was
not could not be brought in into union
with Christ you leave it down in the
waters and that's in terms of
civilization this the same we talk about
how Orthodox he baptizes cultures right
but orthodoxy went into Russia baptized
Russia baptized Rome baptized different
cultures but there are some aspects of
that culture which they got to stay in
the waters and so this is a this is a
kind of very elaborate way to show all
these different things at the same time
yep Oh
so the Acts refers to st. John the
Baptist there st. John the Baptist when
he he's preaching out in the desert he
says the Acts he talks about how people
I need to repent and need to be baptized
and he says the Acts is at the foot of
the tree and he's saying basically the
judgment is coming you need to repent
because soon everything that doesn't
bear fruit is going to be cut off so
that's what that represents yeah sure
well it depends what you mean by icon it
by icon you just mean an image yeah well
for sure for sure the icons of Christ as
we know of they came after the Bible but
it's it's very difficult to it's very
difficult to know what was going on
because because the church was being
persecuted we do have some images here
and there early early images we don't
have a lot and so it's difficult to know
we do know that already in the 2nd
century there is a church that they
found in the city called dura europas
which was it was a home Church which was
next to a synagogue and in that home
church from the 2nd century there they
found two images of Christ one of Christ
healing the paralytic in one of Christ
pulling st. Peter out of the water and
so that's what we have and don't let
historians tell you that that's the
first those are the first icons you know
there may be more some before we have no
idea you know it's just that because the
church are persecuted it's hard to start
to know yeah yeah
most animals comment about a chaotic
part of your existence behind I have a
hard time reconciling that
well let me ask you this do you exercise
the newborn before you baptized yeah you
do yeah so so so even even even even
when we're born we are still st. gregory
of nyssa we do talk about children as
having a certain innocence if that's
true
but st. gregory of nyssa talks about
right there talks about even the child
even the infant who screams for you know
his mother's breast is already showing
the passions you know that he'll have to
deal with later in life and so it's like
we already because we are living in the
body of death the passions and the kind
of art are there very very early yeah
well the snakes underneath the door have
more to do with kind of these these you
know in the baptism prayers if you've
heard the baptism prayers we talked
about these they're great they're my
favorite prayers by the way where it's
like we chase away the dragons that are
in the water and we chase away the
serpent that's hiding at the bottom of
the waters and so we there's this
ancient idea of of these chaotic beings
you know the Leviathan or sea monsters
that hide in the waters and they kind of
represent all of this all of these
things that we exorcise all of these
these these fringe elements of ourselves
that need to be cleansed and so that's
what that is so he's kind of pushing
down the Serpent's yeah the sea serpents
yeah well I was um
I studied contemporary art here at
Concordia and I was at that time I was
in Orthodox I was evangelical and I was
really struggling to unite my faith and
the painting and the fact that you know
that my Christianity contemporary art
and also being a Protestant which is
very iconoclastic and so I was just a
huge struggle and all through college I
was just beating myself over the head
constantly trying to get this to make
sense and then finally I just gave up
and I just destroyed all my paintings
and just decided that's it I'm not gonna
be an artist I'm to be a regular person
and have a job and I'll do that by my
wife thought that was hilarious by the
way she was like yeah you don't know
yourself Jonathan so I that's when I
kind of went through a just a general
spiritual crisis and I and I discovered
the Church Fathers and then I discovered
the traditional art of the church at
first I discovered kind of medieval art
Western medieval art and I thought wow
this is it like this is what I've been
looking for it's just this amazing
language visual language that the whole
church had kind of developed all at the
same time and I thought this is so
powerful and so I was like I want this
like I want to do this and at first I
thought I can't because it's gone it's
medieval Middle Ages are finished but
then I discovered the Orthodox Church
and I discovered the mystical tradition
and ice and I discovered the icon that I
thought yes it's alive and well so I
that's when I became Orthodox and when I
became Orthodox I was when I was a
catechumen I was at the sign of the
Theotokos here and and I wanted to be an
icon so bad it's like just but that
couldn't find the teacher it was I think
now it's easier to find a teacher but at
that time was nearly impossible to find
a teacher and I knew that I couldn't do
it on my own I I just knew that I
couldn't I wasn't wasn't gonna be able
to do it so I was just fuming like just
bubbling inside I would spend all day
and Magill like going through old books
of you know ancient manuscripts and just
you know like medieval images and just
spending all day looking at icons but I
couldn't so
day my parents cut down a linden tree in
their yard and they said hey Jonathan
I hear this tree this woods good for
carving why don't you you want a few
pieces and figure it out and I'm like
yeah I thought I'll make a blessing
cross so I got this piece of linden and
I had no tools basically I had exacto
knives and I like carve this whole cross
out of exacto knives and I still have it
today it's really two testimony to my
shame I just keep it it's very bad but I
still like showed it to the priest was
following me and he was like okay you
know keep going and then I I got some
proper wood into proper tools and I
carved an icon again and this time the
priest is like okay yeah really yeah
keep going and then that was that was it
it was almost like kind of fell
accidentally just out of a desire to
paint icons and not being able to and I
really enjoyed it and I just kept going
and and yeah Here I am very strange yeah
and yeah it is my job like a it's hard
to I don't believe in myself but I do
that the full-time icon Carver yeah
who'd have thought yeah well I mean I
think I think it's kind of like this
weird long process kind of very like
this well at first I read I've heard
that I was kind of reading the Church
Fathers because I'd been told that there
are no Christians from Constantine to
Martin Luther I was like I was pretty
suspicious about that so I just started
reading to church fathers and then
reading st. Augustine at first which was
more accessible and then slowly read and
then when I read st. gregory of nyssa
was like wow this is amazing and like
why did they hide this from me and and
just trying to figure out like how would
this was still alive and I was reading
kind of more traditional authors from
other traditions even from Sufis and and
trying like trying to find my way and
then I found the book the meaning of
icons and that book has an introduction
by vladimir lossky which is just it's
called tradition and traditions and and
it's so weird cuz a lot of people they
really don't like it cuz it's very
technical and very kind of dry I guess
but I was crying it was reading that was
like crying like this is
this is it this is what I've been this
is what I've been looking for and I'd
never been into in an Orthodox Church
yet so you know I just asking around
like where's an Orthodox Church like how
can I find an Orthodox Church and it was
actually a baptist pastor who was
teaching Greek at McGill said I have a
student who's Orthodox maybe you want to
meet him he's like but I'm not sure I
want to give you his number cuz I don't
not sure I want you to go to North
attacked Church but he was joking though
so I did and as soon I went into the
sign of the Theotokos and he was during
Lent and it was during her presanctified
liturgy and so I just walked into this
dark church and it was all prostrations
and and just all you know repentant and
and and father John had such a boy like
a strong voice and and I was like okay
this is it
that is I already knew I was home that
was it
yeah they're right or wrong icons let's
explain there's the oldest one seems
pretty tired traditional but there's
also the wrister depiction of religious
scenes yeah well okay I would say I
would say this is actually a very it's a
very controversial subject right now so
she was my friends from st. Cloud's but
here it's a very it's a very disputed
and controversial subject I think that
how can I say this I think that the in
terms of the iconology I think for sure
they are right and wrong icons that's
for sure that is there some things which
the church has brought together and you
see a consensus in the church about the
manner in which something is represented
and so to go out of that consensus is I
think is problematic that that doesn't
mean there isn't some flexibility within
the image there are there is flexibility
all images are different but there is
there are these these these strains that
these elements that that help us to to
know that that it's that it's that's a
canonical you could say but there is no
official Canon there's no written down
anywhere like this is icon it's good
this icon is bad there were some
discussions in Russia later on about
about that but it's kind of shady some
of some of the because it was it was at
a strange time as for style that is a
more problematic question because for
the same reason there is no NAR no
writings which tell us about style and
there are also when the Western icons
entered into the church no one said
anything no one complained and so the
argument the argument that Western
depictions are fine that's what it's
based on is that no one complained here
are these images
the counter-argument which is one that I
tend to participate in is that even
though even though the church didn't say
anything when the Western icons arrived
and started to become prolific there was
despite that it happened at a time where
the church hit it's crazy time crazy
time in the late 19th and early 20th
century so the Western ideas the Marxist
ideas the nationalist ideas all of these
ideas crept into the churches all of
this crept in and then we saw this smash
at a point where there were no icons
anymore there were no one week no one
was making icons in Russia anymore and
barely anybody was making icons in
Greece and Mount Athos was empty and
that was that now what happens is that
in the restoration of the icon which
happened just two generations ago it's
very recent that we have practiced
practicing iconography is once again in
the restoration of the icon the people
who restore the icon ask themselves
where do we go now and the answer and
sometimes the answer was maybe ill
formulated sometimes they use arguments
which maybe weren't the right types of
arguments but I think the answer they
gave which is we will go back to a time
when Orthodox he was thriving when the
art was thriving when we were building
churches when we didn't have
revolutionaries at the door and that's
what happened and now and so the
restoration of the icon is based on a
reconnection with the 14th to 16th
century iconography that's when that's
when most of the restoration is based
upon but a lot of people will say there
is no theological justification for that
but there is I think a justification for
it which is that it's because we went
there and it's because we looked at
those images that we have a thriving
iconography today if we had just gone to
the Western images
what would what like what would it be
it would not I don't think it would have
had that like that we that were
discovering now so and that's the way it
happened and that's the way it is today
and so I would I warn people not to
argue too strongly against that because
if you don't if you if we think that
iconography is not in danger of dying
once again and that the Orthodox Church
is in danger of dying once again like we
are you have to be seriously naive
because the world does not like us and
so we have to be very attentive to these
things what do you mean in terms of the
ending of icons I mean the end oh I got
that happened in our tradition right the
the ending of icons that happen in our
tradition was a was an outright attack
on orthodoxy itself I mean it was
atheist was that it was this slow
atheist thing that happened I don't mean
I don't mean the Western icons right
away what I mean is what all that led
into it's like when I think that the
iconographies had painted in the western
style I don't blame them and I think
that and I don't have a problem with
venerating those icons either I'm not
I'm not I don't think that they're not
icons and I and I think we have to be
careful not to say that because you'll
hear people say things like if an icon
is painted in the in a western style
it's not an icon and that is that it
hogwash you know a pay up photocopy of
an icon it can be an icon and we know
because we have no bearing icons that
are reproductions we have miracle icons
which are painted in western style all
of this is is real now the question the
question we ask ourselves though is as a
church what do we want to do and as
iconography is what do we want to
promote that's a different that's a
different question
and so but to your question I think that
the end of iconography through all of
this the Western the Western practices
was part of it but it was mostly just
this I mean it was just you know the
Bolsheviks at the door or the
this coming into to cut off the crosses
so if that's what that's what kind of
smashed you know and also Wars is what
kind of smashed iconography dispose of
them yeah well usually you you if you
want to dispose an icon you should burn
it and not throw it away or yeah you
should you should burn it so that it
doesn't so you don't have a decomposing
icon in the trash that would be like
half a half an icon and so so that's how
you should that's how you should but
it's a it's a really complicated
question because the modern world has
really made it difficult to understand
iconography because it's like I you know
you have an icon on your I'm sure you
have an icon here so this this is the
image here in the church right it has a
halo we doesn't have Boyd says st.
George Orthodox Church so it's kind of
the question is you have a picture of an
icon and it has the st. and it has the
name and it has the the halo what is it
an icon what do you do with it it's
complicated it's very very complicated
and so I think that we kind of have to
throw ourselves on the grace of God with
that one but it's very difficult to know
but I think that if you if you know you
have these icons which have been used in
prayer that have participated in the
prayer life of someone somehow then I
think that that you should burn them to
to dispose of them or try to give them
to someone - I cut
yeah yeah I understand I understand I
understand yeah yeah yeah I don't know
I've known I know I have no good answer
for you it's a very different it the the
situation of icons and so one of the you
could say it you could say one of the
things that I think is objective and you
can say is that for an icon to let's say
be a sacred image in the way that we
consider a sacred image that the best
way to understand it that it's
participating in the liturgical life of
the church to a certain extent okay and
so I think that if an image is now
participating in the liturgical life of
the church it's not as big of it as big
a deal you know I mean it's not yeah
it's not it's not it's not a big deal
but I but I'm not saying I don't know
what the answer is to that it's not easy
it's not an easy not an easy answer it's
not an easy question to totally answer
yeah
an economy would bring it to people s
well according so according to the kind
of the very oldest tradition icons were
not blessed one of the arguments that
the that the icon of duels during the
iconoclastic controversy made to to to
the maid was that they they didn't they
didn't bless the icons especially that
they just participated in the life of
the church the way other other things
participated and so we see in the
documents you can find that they weren't
blessing icons but I don't I think it's
fine to bless icons it's not a bless
everything right
bless cars bless so it's no I don't I
don't think that I don't think that it's
not it's not an icon but that but I
think there's nothing it's it can be
good to have an icon bless just because
just because it brings it into the life
of the church you know it's like your
spiritual authority your priest is going
to you know he's going to pray over that
icon you know he prays over you so it's
like this whole prayer relationship
that's going on and so I think that that
is that it's that it can be good to do
that also when you take that icon and
you bring it home you're going to also
carry that with you carry that whole
blessing with you whereas you're going
to consider this image maybe you'll take
more care of it you'll have more
attention to it and you won't take it as
as lightly as you might if you didn't so
I think that it's a fine practice
there's some people were like against
blessing icons and there's some people
who say that you if you don't bless an
icon then you can't you can't you can't
use it in prayer I think we need to find
a normal like a normal way
I've middle-way all right
well everybody I really appreciate your
attention thank you for listening to me
and and I wish you all the best on this
mentoring program sounds like a lot of
fun so thanks father Justin
[Applause]